[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه وهذه
يا عناوين
بايدا اني استقبلوا زلنسكي في البيت
الابيض واشنطن تستبق اللقاء بالاعلان عن
دعم عسكريا لاوكرانيا اهمها بالفريق
[موسيقى]
بعد النوويه بوتن يستفزوا الغرب بالاعلان
عن تطوير المسيارات واداره بايدون تشدد
صادراتها التقنيه التقنيه
على خلفيه الاعدامات في ايران واشنطن تفرض
عقوبات جديده ضد المدعي العام وقاده في
الحرس الدوري
[موسيقى]
طالبان تسرق حلم النساء بالتعليم تغلق
الجامعات في وجههن وتتحدى الاذنات وتؤكد
انها لن تتراجع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
ضيفنا خاص حتى الرحاله في واشنطن ليصنع
الحدث من هناك ويصب الزيت على نار
التوترات هناك في حرب افرانها الحديث هنا
عن
سبير رئيس الاوكراني الذي يقوم بزياره
تاريخيه لواشنطن يقابلها خلالها الرئيس
الامريكي مشهدا تعتبره روسيا تسخينا لجبهه
الصراع زياره خلفت وراءها سيلا من الاسئله
لماذا في هذا التوقيت بالذات والى ماذا
ستضضي انظروا موسكو اتجهت الى واشنطن
تترقب ما ستجود به هذه الزياره التي تعد
اول رحله خارجيه لزيننسكي منذ بدء الحرب
في اوكرانيا
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن استقبل زيننسكي
في البيت الابيض واجرا معه لقاءا اعلن
خلاله ان الولايات المتحده ستزود اوكرانيا
بمنظومه صواريخ باتريوت لتعزيز دفاعاتها
الجويه
وسوف نزودها بانظمه الصواريخ
قواتكم ليتمكن من استخدام الصواريخ مستمر
من جانبياتنا الرئيس الاوكراني بلودمير
زيلينسكي على دعم الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا وقال خلال حديثه ان الحربه لم
تنتهي بعد
لدينا قضايا مهمه لمناقشتها وهناك تحديات
كثيره في اوكرانيا وفي اوروبا وفي العالم
انطلاقا من الطاقه والوضع في ساحه المعركه
اود تاكيد من صميم فؤادي على تقدير نيابه
عن الشعب الاوكراني والامه الاوكرانيه لكم
سيدي الرئيس على دعمكم الكبير والدور
القيادي الذي قمتم به من خلال مساعدتكم
لنا لان الحرب لم تنتهي بعد اشكركم سيدي
الرئيس على الدعم واشكر الحزبين والشعب
الامريكي على الدعم اشكر الشعب الامريكي
نيابه عن الشعب الاوكراني شكرا جزيلا لكم
رئيس زيلانكي وصل الى قاعده اندروزا
الجويه العسكريه في ولايه ميريلاند على
متن طائره امريكيه تابعه للرئاسه بهدف
حمايته من اي استخدام طبعا غادر بلاده الى
بولندا المجاوره ومنها انطلق الى امريكا
لان الطيران المدني لا يمر عبر سماء
اوكرانيا وسط الطائرات الحربيه والصواريخ
هذه اول رحله خارجيه لزيننسكي منذ بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا
البلبيسي مراسله العربيه ناديه اهلا بك
اخر هذه الزياره او تسريبات هذه الزياره
هناك تسريبات
اهلا بك يا عادل طبعا ننتظر الان لقاء
مطول سيجمع رزلنسكي مع بايرن هنا خلفي في
البيت الابيض في المكتب البيضاوي بتحديد
وسيمضم الى الوفدين طبعا وفد عسكري وسيكون
هناك وفد امني من البيت الابيض سيدم طبعا
جيكسن ومستشارين كبار للرئيس لكن اعتقد
بانه هذه الزياره التي حاطتها الكثير من
السريه البيت الابيض قال لنا بان بيض هو
الذي داز الانسكي الى الحضور هنا في
الحادي عشر من ديسمبر تاكدت هذه الزياره
فقط يوم الاحد ربما انت تسالت قبل قليل
كنت اسمعك عادل لماذا الان التوقيت اعتقد
بان التوقيت رغم ان البيت الابيض لا يؤكد
هذا الا ان التوقيت اعتقد بانه كما تعرف
الكونغرس الجديد همم يبدا مهام اعماله في
بدايه يناير وبالتالي هذه الفرصه الوحيده
لنانسي كلوسي كرئيسه لمجلس الن بان ترحب
بياذينسكي لان يقدم ربما خطاب يناشد فيه
الاعضاء الكونجرس باستمرار بتقديم الدعم
العسكري لقاء في البيت الابيض يعطيه زخم
واهميه كبرى لانه الرئيس بايرن يستقبله
هنا وبالتالي اعتقد كان هناك تخوف من بعض
الاطراف وخصوصا بان كيف المقاس وهو محتمل
الرئيس القادم لمجلس النواب قال باننا لا
نقدم شيك على بياض بمعنى منه الدعم
العسكري سيقل ومن هنا البيت الابيض حرص
على ان يكون موجود اليوم في هذه الزياره
بالفعل البعض يرها التاريخيه اتى قبل قليل
زينسكي هنا يلبس تقريبا الزي العسكري وقدم
الى بيض المداليه عسكريه من كابتن يخدم في
الجيش الاوكراني قال هذه عندما قلت له انا
ساذهب للقاء بايدا قال له بانه هذا رئيس
شجاع لانه يقدم هذا الدعم لي اوكرانيا
طبعا كما تعرف موضوع الدعم وحشد تاييد
العالمي هو ليس فقط لان الاداره تؤمن منذ
اليوم الاول بان روسيا انتهت السياده
الاوكرانيه لكن هو دفاعا اوروبا بشكل عام
وعن الديمقراطيات واعتقد بانه اللقاء الذي
سيجمع ايضا بيضا عفوا زنسكي بعد خروجه من
البيت الابيض مع المشارعين في الكونجرس
امام مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ مهم جدا
لاستمرار هذا الدعم وطبعا لحج التاييد ليس
فقط التايد رسمي لكن ايضا تاييد شعبي همم
نقطه ثانيه هو انه بعد اللقاء الثنائي
سيكون هناك مؤتمر صحفي سيجمع زنسكي مع
بايدن همم في داخل البيت الابيض خلال
تقريبا ساعه من ال-
الدعم الذي ستقدمه واشنطن هل همم
الباتريوت على راس هذه القائمه هل من مزيد
نعم صواريخ الباتيه على الراس هذه القائمه
هذا هو كان طلب اوكراني منذ فتره طويله
بان ربما الجيش الاوكراني لا يستطيع ان
يواجه صواريخ الروسيه بالدفاع نفسي كما
تفعل مثلا اسرائيل امام صواريخ حماس او
غيرها من حلفاء الولايات المتحده لكن
الاداره كانت تتخوف بان استخدامات
الصواريخ وخصوصا منظومه اللي هي بحاجه الى
تدريب كبير جدا ومن هنا حرس البيت الابيض
على اخبارنا ليله امس بانه سيكون هناك
تدريب على اعلى مستوى للقوات الاوكرانيه
في بلد ثالث اعتقد بانه سيكون بولندا بعد
ذلك سيتم تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه الصواريخ
التي سيعلن عنها البيت الابيض بدون ادنى
شك في اللقاء الصحفي خلال ساعه لكن اعتقد
بانه همم هناك شروط امريكيه وهو عدم
استخدام هذه اي من هذه الاسلحه
للهجوم على روسيا وبالتالي هي تركز منذ
الاول على انها دفاعيه بامتياز وليست
هجوميه عاد عن ذلك هناك قبل قليل
البنتاجون اصدر تفاصيل عن كل هذه الاسلحه
والمبالغ يعني
1.8 مليار دولار يعني مبلغ كبير جدا على
ان الميزانيه حتى التي سيقرها الرئيس
ميزانيه الكونجرس التي عطلت تقريبا همم
يعني كانت تهدد باغلاق الحكومه فيها
عفوا 40 40 مليار دولار مساعدات ايضا
قادمه لاوكرانيا هذه معركه مستمره معركه
طويله يراها البيت الابيض بانها كما قلت
هي دفاع عن سياده اوروبا وعن حريات اوروبا
راس الحربه هي اوكرانيا وهو يريد ان يحجم
النفود الروسي ومن هنا زياره جينز كيا
رساله موجهه لروسيا ولبوتن اكثر ربما من
تكون رساله للعالم ولتحالف وحتى للجمهوريه
العربيه من واشنط شكرا جزيلا لك
قبل ان تحط طائر الزيننسكي بساعات في
واشنطن كما ذكرنا قبل قليل اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو بلانكين
للتخصيص 850 مليون دولار مساعدات لي
اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى مليار دولار لتطوير
الدفاعات الجويه وتزويد كيبل لاول مره
بمنظومه
للدفاع الجوي
الكرملين طبعا لم يخفي انزعجه
حيث قال انه لا يتوقع تغيرا في موقفكير
بشان المفاوضات السلام بعد هذه الزياره
لان مصدر القلق الرئيسي لروسيا في هذه
الحرب هو الاسلحه الغربيه فقد عاد الكرمله
ليحذر مره اخرى من توريد المزيد من
الاسلحه الامريكيه لكيف معتبرا ان ذلك
سيؤدي لتفاكم
لكن صمود كيف الى حد كبير في هذه الحرب
ونجاحها في تحقيق العديد من المكاسب يرجع
فيه الفضل بشكل كبير الى المساعدات
الغربيه سيما الامريكيه منها فماذا قدمت
الولايات المتحده لاوكرانيا اكد من عسكري
في هذه الحرب منذ بدايتها
[موسيقى]
صراع الاسلحه بيت القصيده في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
والبحث عن امدادات اخرى حتى انت طلب الامر
الاستعانه بالطرف المنافس الموضوع ينقلنا
للحديث عن تهريب معدات امريكيه الى روسيا
لتطويل الاسلحه هناك شبكه
في التحقيق في كيفيه وصول مكونات
الامريكيه الى اسلحه تستخدمها روسيا تشمل
هذه المكونات تقنيات الكترونيه دقيقه
امريكيه صنع
سيارات ايرانيه تطلق روسيا على اوكرانيا
هذا واقامه منظمه ابحاث التسلح في
النزاعات ومقرها بريطانيا الشهر الماضي
بفحص طائرات تم اسقاطها في اوكرانيا وجدت
ان 82% من مكون من مكونات هذه المسيارات
تم تصنيعها بواسطه شركات امريكيه التحقيق
كشف النقاب ايضا عن تطور جديد يفيد ان
روسيا تستعد لفتح مصنع خاص لانتاج
المسيارات داخل روسيا كجزء من صفقه مع
ايران
تطورنا يعززه كلام الرئيس الروسي خلال
خطاب الخط العسكريه الجديده حيث شدد على
ضروره الانتاج المسيررات الجويه والبحريه
باحدث المواصفات القتاليه مضيفا في خطابه
امام وزاره الدفاع ان العمليه العسكريه
اظهرت اهميه استخدام المسيرات
ان استخدام المسيارات اصبح امرا واقعا
لذلك لابد من العمل على هذا الموضوع وخبره
استخدام المسيرات يجب ان تكون لدى كل مجلد
وهذا يجب تنفيذه في القريب العاجل لابد من
انتاج المسيرات الجويه والبحريه باحدث
المواصفات القتاليه
اهلا بك سيدي يعني ابدا عن هذه الموسيقى
التي دخلت ويريد
بوتن تطويرها لاستخدامها هل اصبحت هي اا
احدى اهم الوسائل في تغيير الاستراتيجيه
الحربيه في اوكرانيا
واجرام
منذ عام 2014
وفي ذلك الوقت روسيا كانت لها اليد العليا
في استخدام المسيارات فقد حصلت روسيا على
التكنولوجيا سيارات من اسرائيل ولم يكن
لدى اوكرانيا
ربما لديها نفس الامكانات اوكرانيا من حيث
المسارات وبالتالي فيا تحتاج لانواع مطوره
من السيارات ويترغب في انتاجها
وترى روسيا اليوم انها متاخره في هذا
المجال لذلك في تسعه للحصول على الوعاء
مختلفه من المسيرات مثل مسيرات المسيرات
الهجوميه وم مرات الاستطلاع الصغيره
والكبيره منها وللهذا في الواقع ما تحدث
عن الرئيس الروسي الذي قال انه هناك حاجه
لتوفير هذه المسيارات للجنود على سحب في
ساحه
المعركه وهذا شيء جيد بان تدرك القياده
الروسيه
مشاكل
ما تحتاج اليه روسيا وبسرعه المطلوبه
نعم ارجو ان تبقى معي دعنا نستمع الى جانب
اخر تحدث عنه بوتين تطوير مسيرات كانت فقط
رساله واحده من تلك الرسائل التي وجهها
بوتين في خطابه اليوم فقد لو واحد بما هو
اخطر من المسيارات القدره النوويه التي
اعلن بوتن ان روسيا طورتها بنسبه 91%
وكانه يطلق سباق تسلح نووي في العالم
النوويه ما يمثل ضمانا لسياده روسيا ووحده
اراضيها وبشكل عام الرد على النووي
والتوازن النووي في العالم وقد تم تجهيز
القوات النوويه بنسبه 91% وايضا تم تزويد
قواتنا بمنظومه فرط الصوتيه وايضا تم
تزويد القوات للمره الاولى بمنظومه
الصواريخ العابره
وزير الدفاع الروسيه سيرجيو شدد عقيدا على
جاهزيه سلاح النوويه الروسيه وتزويد
القوات العسكريه باسلحه جديده ومتطوره
على تزويد القوات باسلحه جديده عاليه
الكفاءه وتسليحي ثلاثه افواجا بصوارخ من
طرازي ياريس
سيدي يعني قبل قليل تحدثنا عن المسيارات
الان نتحدث عن قوه الرد على النووي التي
دائما ما نتحدث عنها 91% ليست بالامر
الهين ولا بالتالي عمليه خلق الميزان جديد
في مواجهه
والغرب وليس فقط اوكرانيا بالسلاح النووي
الى اين يقودنا
ازيكم
النوويه
خلال الصراع في اوكرانيا
يعني ربما
المحاوله الوصول الى مستويات اعلى في
الجوزي
اوكرانيا
ايضا لكن اليسرى وبريطانيا
ههه او ربما الشيخ الدعم الابتزاز قد ايه
ينجح لكن هذا سلاحا ذو حدين لانه يعمل في
الاتجاهين واستخدام الاسلحه النوويه هي
قصه مختلفه تماما مما استخدام سوف يتعرض
المنيا يستخدمها لهجوم النووي ايضا
وبالتالي تجاوز العتب النوويه ليست خيار
قابل للحياه ولكن التهديد بهذه الاسئله
الجديده التي تحدث عنها
وهي تظهر بانها الرافعه النووي الروسي
موجود بريطانيا
لدى اي طرف تفوقا في هذا المجال من موسكو
بافيل » المحلل العسكري شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
اضرابات بريطانيا تتسع اخر المنظمين طواقم
سيارات الاسعاف
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
فرض عقوبات جديده ضد ايران تشمل حزمه
العقوبات ثلاثه من قاده الحرس الثوري
والبسيج والمسؤولين عن قمع الاحتجاجات
خاصه في محافظات كردستان ايراني اضافه الى
المدعي العام في طهران محمد منتظر بسبب
محاكمات واعدامات المحترفين
قمع هو الاحتجاجات في ايران جعل طهران
بالاضافه الى العقوبات عرضه لسيد متواصل
من الانتقادات والتمديدات اخر اتهام
موجهتهم منظمته هيومن رايتس ووتش الى قوات
الامن الايرانيه باستخدام القوه المفرطه
غير القانونيه والمفضيه للموت ضد
المتظاهرين في مدينه سرندل ودعتها المنظمه
التي مقرها نيويورك باعثه الامم المتحده
لتقص الحقائق بشان ايران للتحقيق في هذه
الانتهاكات الجسيمه ونقل بيان للمنظمه
تاكيدا على ممارسه السلطات الايرانيه عنفا
مقلقا ضد المتظاهرين في سلندر سبتمبر
الماضي
اذا في هذا الخبر العاجل لا مراسله
العربيه مقتل ثلاثه جنود في حصيله اوليه
في انفجار الجراء عبوه ناسفه قرب كركوك
اظهرت بياناته شحنا ان عشرات السفن
التجاريه المحمله بالحبوب والسكر عالقه
قباله الموانئ الايرانيه بعد تاخرها
لاسابيع اذ تعطل تعطل المشكلات الدفع تدفق
البضائع الى البلاد ما يفاقم الازمه التي
تعيشها ايران
ايران على صفيح ساخن الاحتجاجات في
الشوارع ضد السلطات وازمه اقتصاديه خانقه
تضرب البلاد النظام المالي على جفل انهيار
ان لم يكن انهار فعلا 10 سفن التجاريه
المحمله بالمواد الغذائيه عالقه قباله
الموانئ الايرانيه بعد تاخرها لاسابيع
مشكله الدفع تعطل تدفق البضائع
البيانات اظهرت عدم قدره السفن على تفريغ
شحنتها ما لا يقل عن اربعين ناقله سائبه
عالقه خارج من اي بندر الخميني وبندر عباس
وهما من الموانئ الايرانيه الرئيسيه منظمه
الموانئ والملاحه البحريه الايرانيه قالت
ان نحو 37 سفينه تحمل مليونين ومئتي الف
طن من الفضائع لم تتمكن من تفريغ حمولاتها
بسبب عوائق خاصه بالمستندات والسداد
بالعمله الصعبه القوى الغربيه اعفت الموا
عند الغذائيه من عقوباتها المفروضه على
ايران بسبب برنامجها النووي لكن تاثير
العقوبات على النظام المالي الايراني جعل
تسديد ايران لمدفوعتها للشركات الدوليه
امرا معقدا
ويمثل الامن الغذائي اولويه بالنسبه
لايران ازاله الحاجه الى الواردات
الغذائيه بسبب الجفاف الذي اضر بانتاج
الغذاء المحلي لموسمين متتاليين لكن
استمرار الازمه السياسيه الخانقه يجعل
النظام عاجزا عن توفير اساسيه الحياه ما
يهدد بسقوطه وفق خبراء بلال الوجدان
العربيه
[موسيقى]
طلع وزير القوات المسلحه المسلحه
البريطانيه في لقاء خاص مع العربيه ان
التحالف الدوليه الذي يعمل في منطقه في
المنطقه سيستمر معتبرا ان محاولات ايران
لتعمي ميليشيات الحوثي في اليمن ستتلاشى
وابقى تعبيره
الدوليه الذي يعمل في المنطقه سيستمر
ومحاوله ايران لدعم الحوثيين ستتلاشى وكما
نتوقع هناك الكثير من الاساليب المبتكره
لجمع الادله الاستخباراتيه واساليب
المراقبه من اجل خفض احتماليه ايصال
الاسلحه ووقف كل السفن بريطانيا والحلفاء
على اهبه الاستعداد دائما لتقديم عمل افضل
لعرقله وصول هذه الشحنات الى الحوثيين
واضاف وزير القوات المسلحه البريطانيه
جيمس هيبي في لقاء خاص مع العربيه ان هناك
مجالات كثيره للتعاون بين بريطانيا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه مشيرا ان بلاده
والرياض ولديهما رؤيه مشتركه لامن المنطق
المنطقه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه عملنا على
اشياء كثيره عبر سنوات طويله اخرى
ومتطلبتها وكيف بامكان السعوديه وبريطانيا
العمل من اجل تحقيقها
[موسيقى]
هذه هي المقابله الخاصه ستاتيكم في تمام
الساعه 1:00 بتوقيت السعوديه الثانيه
والعشرين بتوقيت تاجر كامله مع وزير
القوات البريطانيه
الى خبرنا خبر على ابواب جامعتهن المغلقه
واحلامهن المعلقه وقفنا وقفت الطالبات
الافغانيات يشاهدنا بالم كيف ذهب
الطموحاتهن ادراج الرياح قالت بعد
الطالبات لقد سرقوا من الامل ودفنوا
احلامنا انهم طالبان هذه الحركه التي حرمت
النساء حقوقهن في افغانستان
البدايه كانت بمنع الحركه منذ توليها
السلطه تعليم المرحله
من قيود على اللباس والترفيه وغيرها وصولا
الى منع الفتيات من التعليم الجامعي ورغم
التمديد والتحذير
طالبان بتنفيذ قرارها ضد الفتيات واغلقت
بالفعل ابواب الجامعات في وجههن اليوم
ونشرت حراس مسلحين منعوا الطالبات من
دخولهن الى الحرم الجامعي ليعكس المشهد
صوره واضحه على الاضطهاد ضد المراه
وعود لم نرى اي ضغوط من قبل المجتمع
الدولي على حكم طالبان ما نراه في الواقع
هو ان الظلم والتعسف لا يزال مستمرا
الفتيات لا يستطيعن الذهاب للمدارس
والنساء لا يستطيعن الذهاب الى الجامعات
ليس هناك اي احترام لحقوق الانسان في
افغانستان حتى من يرفعنا اصواتهن ويقومنا
بالاحتجاج يتم اسكاتهن والمجتمع الدولي
صامت
القرار اثار موجه غضب واسع في افغانستان
قدم اساتذه جامعيون استقالتهم احتجاجا على
منع الفتيات من التعليم دوليا تتواصل ردود
الفعل المهدده بقرار طالبان اخرها من
الاتحاد الاوروبيه الذي اعتبر قرار طالبان
جريمه ضد الانسانيه الامين العام للامم
المتحده
ابدا قلقه العميق معتبرا ان منع الفتيات
من ارتياد الجامعات سيكون مدمرا على
البلاد السعوديه
من جانبها اعلانات وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ان حكومه طالبان قررت تدمير
مستقبلها افغانستان بحضر التعليم الجامعي
على النساء رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه قال
ان القرار مرفوض ويعكس خطوه كبيره للوراء
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر عن ان
طبعا السبعه تعمل على ادانه ومحاسبه
المسؤولين عن قرار منع الفتيات من التعليم
طالبان ردا على كل تلك الادانه قالت انها
لن تتراجع عن قرارها ولن تفسر افعالها
لاحد
[موسيقى]
اذا هذا البيان المشترك لمجموعه السبع
والاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو طالبان للتراجع عن
قرار منع تعليم النساء
نذهب الى خبرنا الاخر
يبدو ان موجه الاضرابات في بريطانيا لم
تعد تستثني اي فئه عماليه اخر المنضمين
الى الفئات المطربه عمال سيارات الاسعاف
الذين التحقوا بزملائهم الممرضين
في وقت السابق الالاف من طواقم سيارات
الاسعاف الخدميه والصحيه والوطنيه في
بريطانيا
تعبيرا عن رفض الحكومه زياده الاجور
اضرابات القطاعات الصحيه لا تروق بالمره
للحكومه البريطانيه حيث دخل وزير الصحه
والرعايه الاجتماعيه على الخط داعيا
المطربين الى تحكيم العقل مشيرا الى ان
الاضراب ياتي في وقت تواجه فيه هيئه
الخدمات الصحيه الوطنيه بالفعل ضغوطا
هائله للغايه ثم وضع الجيش في حاله تاهب
للمساعده في قياده مركبات
الطوارئها الا ان الجنود لن يكونوا مخولين
بجميع الصلاحيات التي يتم تاع بها سائق
سيارات الاسعاف
معنى من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
مصطفى اهلا بك يعني لو تجمل لنا ما الذي
يحدث الان هل بالفعل هذه المستشار
المستشفيات قد تم تعطيل حركه سيارات
الاسعاف بها ام ان هناك جزء من الممكن ان
يخدم المرضى او الحالات الطارئه
بشكل عام المستشفيات هي اهدى اليوم من
الايام العاديه بسبب هذا الاضراب للمسعفين
الذي يشمل ايضا الفنيين وايضا من يتلقون
الاتصالات من عامه الشعب لمن يريدون همم
سياره اسعاف بالطبع كان هناك جزء بسيط من
من قدموا هذه الخدمات وهناك فئه معينه
خاصه اولئك الذي لا تتعرضون لسكتات قلبيه
هم في يعني الدرجه الاولى التي يتم
الاستجابه لنداءاتهم واتصالاتهم بالاضافه
الى ان هناك ايضا بعض الحالات الصحيه مثل
همم الالم في الصدر يمكن التعامل معها
بحسب بعض النقابات ليس كل ليست ليست كل ان
نقبات توافق على على ان تتعامل مع الفئه
الثانيه من الحالات ولكن الفئه الثالثه
والرابعه ليست هناك اي اتصالات وقد واحده
بان حتى الاتصالات
يعني كانت همم يعني قليله مقارنه بالايام
العاديه وهذا مؤشر على ان الناس ربما
استمعوا الى نصائح نقابات وايضا يعرفون ما
يجري وبالتالي لن لم يتصلوا وهناك ايضا من
يقوم بهذه الاتصالات خلال اليومين المقبلا
وهذا لا يعني بان الايام ستكون عاديه جدا
لانه هناك مكان من كان بحاجه الى همم الى
معين من قبل همم المستشفى اخرها اليوم او
يومين وبالتالي اليومين المقبلان ستكون
هناك العديد من من اولئك الذين يعانون من
امراض يريدون ان هذه يعني داخل المستشفيات
يعني الى الان لم تظهر هذه المشكله بشكل
بشكل كبير اليوم هذه همم ربما الشدو والجد
من الحكومه والمضربين من سيصرخ اولا هل
الحكومه في بوادر استجابه ما هي بالفعل
المتماسك كبيره ورافضه لاي نقاش مع
المغربي
ما يمكن ملاحظته عادل بان الحكومه تحاول
ان تلوم النقبات المصره على هكذا اتخاذ
اضرابات في وقت يعني حرج جدا
يعني بالتعبير بان همم وزير الصحه قال بان
النقابات اتخذت هذا قرار الاضراب بشكل
واعرض صحه عامه الناس الى الخطر وبالتالي
هذا اللون والتبادل لاتهامات بين الجانبين
لن يتوقف ولكن الحكومه مصره على ان تستمر
في تعنتها وان كان هناك اقبال او دعم كبير
من عامه الشعب 54% ايدون هذه الاضرابات
وان كانت همم كانت يعني بعض بعض الحالات
لن يتم همم
معالجتها او او النظر في في همم في حالتها
المرضيه والطبع هذا مؤسف جدا كما يقول
وزير الصحه شكرا
لندن
[موسيقى]
في اطار ردود الفعل على قرار طالبان حظر
التعليم الجامعي على الفتيات شرب ايام
مشترك لمجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
الى الان
الى ان طالبا مصممه على محو النساء من
الحياه العامه وانه تم رصد 16 قرارا
لطالبان ضد النساء البيان دعا الحركه الى
التراجع فورا عن قرار منع تعليم النساء
واضاف البيان ان الطالبان تعمل على عزل
نفسها داخليا وخارجيا
منك ابو المراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر
ينضم الينا عبد الله اجمل لنا ما هي ردود
الفعل في الداخل الافغاني سواء المؤيد او
حتى المعارض لها ال قرار طالبات
ردود الفعل
قراره طالبان دخل اليوم حيز التنفيذي وقد
قامت القوات الامنيه وايضا مسؤول الجامعات
بمنع الفتيات من الدخول الى الجامعات هذا
القرار اثار حفيظه الاوساط الافغانيه
الثقافيه وتحديدا السيدات والفتيات ثم ان
طالبان لم تقدم تغيرات او اي تفاص عن هذا
القرار
في وقت ادى القرار الى انتقادات لاذعه
والى استقاله عدد من الاساتذه الجامعيين
قبل قليل كنت اتابع احدى القنوات
التلفزيونيه المحليه وشاهدت جايد مومندو
وهو واستاذن جميعي مشهور قدم استقالته على
الهواء محتجا على هذا القرار ما يهمه هل
ستثنى هذه الاحتجاجات والاستقالات
والانتقادات الداخليه والخارجيه طالبان عن
قرارها همم بحسب معرفه بطالبان فان طالبان
لم يثنيه شيء عن هذا القرار فهي صامده
وقراراتها صارمه لا تراجع عنها في وقت همم
تعلن او اعلنت مجموعات من السيدات
والطالبات الجامعيات تنظيم التظاهرات
الاحتجاجيه ان غدا امام البوابه الرئيسيه
لجامعه كابول اكبر واشهر جامعه في
افغانستان هناك انتقادات لاذعه
تظاهرات كانت قد درمت اليوم في مقاطعات
مختلفه اذا هذا القرار في وقت الندد ايضا
بالقرار حامد كرزه الرئيس الاسبق
لافغانستان معتبرا هذا القرار بانه قرار
مقلق وان التعليم يجب ان يتوفر للجميع
بنات وبنين
عبد الله نادر مراسل العربيه من كابل شكرا
جزيلا لك
قبل ان نذهب الى الفاصل ان نذكر بالخبر
العاجل الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبعه
يقولون ان هذا القرار لطالبان سيدفعنا
لاتخاذ اجراء ضد طيبه ايضا نتابع في اخبار
الساعه
لماذا تعتبر واشنطن تيك توك تحديدا لامنها
القوميه التجسس ام التضليل
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله تتزايد تحذيرات في الولايات
المتحده من تطبيق تيك توك ومن المخاطر
التي تشكلها روابطه مع الصين على الامن
القومي
[موسيقى]
ملف متجدد للولايات المتحده دفعها
للمطالبه مرارا بحذف المنصه الامر الذي
فتح باب التساؤل حول الاسباب
[موسيقى]
تدور حدود منتقدي تك توك حول الوصول الى
بيانات المستخدمين من داخل اعلى هرم
السلطه في بكين لكن بعض الخبراء يعتبرونها
مخاوف ومبالغه فيها فالعديد من الجهه
يمكنه الوصول للبيانات
تقوم الشركات باستمرار بجمع كميات هائله
من البيانات سواء كانت شركات امريكيه او
اجنبيه
[موسيقى]
وهو الامر نفسه الذي ينطبق على بقيه
التطبيقات
مع التيك توك قد نقوم بتثبيت الاصدار
الصيني من بيجاسوس على هواتفنا ذكيه اعتقد
ان هذا هو ما يقلق الحكومه في الولايات
المتحده
[موسيقى]
من المخاطر المرتبطه بتك توك امكانيه قيام
السلطات الصينيه بمراقبه محتوى معين
لتماشي مع سياستها بالتالي تشكيل المشهد
العام للمستخدمين وفقا للسيناريو الذي
يرضيها وهو متن في تيك توك القيامه به
[موسيقى]
امر اخر يسيروا قلقه واشنطن اذا تيك توك
هو احتمال وتعديل المحتوى للتوجه السياسي
للتاثير على الرايسه وتعطي للعمليه
الديمقراطيه على غرار الحمله الروسيه قبل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2016
وردت المنصه علي تلك الثغرات بتدابير
للتحقق من الحسابات الحكوميه والسياسيه
[موسيقى]
يبقى العداء التاريخي بين النسر الامريكي
والتنين الصيني بعض الخبراء يشككون في
قدرته تيك توك في واشنطن التي نبذت منصه
من حيث المبدا بسبب علاقتها مع الصين روان
حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
نجح باحثون في جامعه جنوب كنز الامريكيه
في تطوير الروبوت جديد مصنوع من ماده
هلاليه يزحف مثل الدود داخل الجسم الانسان
يتحرك الروبوت الدوده دون بطاريات او
اسلاك او اي مصدر طاقه خارجي
تقلص وتمدد الماده الفلاميه وتتم صناعه
هذه الروبوتات الهلاميه بالطباعه الثلاثيه
الابعاد ما يسمح بانتاجها بكميات كبيره
يعمل الفريق العلمي في الاعتماد على
الروبوتات الدوده لعلاج السرطانات التي
تستطيع ايصال الدواء الى المنطقه المصابه
مباشره
[موسيقى]
في وقفتنا اليوميه حتى نهايه العام نتوقف
مع ابرز احداث فبراير هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يونس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في نهايه
يستقبل زرنس كيف البيت الابيض واشنطن
تستبق اللقاء بالاعلاني عن دعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا همها بالبترول
بعد النوويه بوتين يستفز الغرب الاعلامي
عن تطوير المسيرات واداره بايدينت تشدد
صادرات تقنياتها
على خلفيه الاعدامات في ايران واشنطن
تفضوا عقوبات جديده ضد المدعي العام وقاده
في الحرس الثوري
طالبان تسرق حلم النساء بالتعليم تغلق
الجامعات في وجههن وتتحدى الادانه وتاكد
انها لن تتراجع
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه والقاكم على راس
الساعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]